tom felton matthew lewis and rupert
grint were just a few of the people
injured on the set of harry potter
the crew tried to keep everyone safe but
there were a few blunders
like one that left daniel ratcliffe at
the bottom of a 20-foot deep tank of
water from toppling towers to badly
behaved broomsticks
let's explore the series most dangerous
scenes
devin let's bring him down james and
oliver phelps were always down to try
some stunts themselves
they trained for this scene where fred
and george are blasted away from the
goblet after sneaking their names in
but the professionals decided that it
would be too dangerous to hook the
actors up to wires and
yank them away from the goblet they had
stunt performers do it instead
and they were right it was way too
dangerous and one of the doubles ended
up dislocating his shoulder
ready fred ready george bottoms up
for most of the movies daniel
ratcliffe's main stunt double was this
talented gymnast david holmes
but one tricky scene in deathly hallows
didn't go as planned
leaving holmes seriously injured this
scene required holmes to be yanked
backwards during a controlled explosion
as nagini attacked
but holmes was accidentally thrown
against the wall he tragically suffered
a broken neck and was left paralyzed
he's now in a wheelchair and this scene
became the most devastating moment of
the entire series
it was just a rehearsal that went wrong
and unfortunately i had my injury
there were a lot of pyrotechnics
involved in the battle of hogwarts so
the cast had to avoid
all those flames most of the fire was
set to a castle mock-up which was made
of timber
steel and plastic but when the flames
went a little out of control it caught
fire for real
and quickly spread to the actual
hogwarts set the fire was put out in 40
minutes and only destroyed an exterior
courtyard
so thankfully no one was hurt well i
must say i'd hoped
for better when harry falls down the
roof in this scene
versus the hungry horntail daniel was
really hanging
40 feet up in the air attached to some
wires he was dropped suddenly and slid
to the ground just as planned
but it was absolutely terrifying daniel
said he saw his life flash before his
eyes as he fell to the ground
but thankfully the wires were there to
catch him and he had a good laugh about
it in the end
that was really really terrifying and
i'm not afraid to admit that
that was really scary hermione giving
draco a taste of his own medicine was
more dangerous in real life
than we would have thought emma and tom
talked before filming about making the
slap in this scene look more realistic
slap me she's like no i'm not gonna
slide let's go on slap me right now
let's just do this to the emotions
but tom never expected to actually get
punched in the face
the punch left him with a ringing in his
ears and a pretty sore head for the rest
of the day
and now we all know that emma watson has
a pretty mean right hook
i feel really bad i'm not really sure
what i was thinking
speaking of accidental injuries caused
by cast members
who would have thought that in this
scene helena bonham carter was
actually hurting matthew lewis helena
decided to take a cue from bellatrix's
wicked ways and taunted neville by
putting her wand right in his ear but
matthew lewis moved at the same time
and the wand ended up perforating his
eardrum helena felt
terrible but she didn't really know how
much damage she'd done until matthew
complained of his ear bleeding
three days later i'm definitely milking
every moment
for the second try wizard task the cast
had to go
underwater but it was a lot more
complicated than it sounds
they used a giant 20-foot deep tank to
film the scene and daniel was taught
some diving signals so that he could let
the professionals know if he was in
danger
or running out of oxygen over the course
of three weeks he spent more than 41
hours underwater
the longest dive being 75 minutes but
at one point during filming he got the
signals messed up and instead of telling
his diving instructor he was okay
he signaled that he was drowning causing
them to rush him to the surface
it's a good thing he didn't mix the
signals up when he really was running
out of oxygen or
things could have gone a lot worse this
means
quick i'm drowning get me up to the
surface whereas to me that means hey i'm
fine
tom felton had to brave toppling towers
for this room of requirement scene
it's easy to think all of this stuff is
done with cgi
but no tom felton and louis cordes who
plays blaise zabini
were really at the top of the pile of
furniture that was raked to fall
they were hooked up to wires the whole
time but tom admitted it was his
scariest scene to film out of the entire
series
we can definitely see why that table
falling out from underneath them
is nightmare material smiling now only
because my feet are on the floor
this same room of requirement scene was
also the first time in the series that
the stunt coordinators had to put more
than one person on a broom
at the same time that means they had to
reinforce the back so they could do a
drive by where daniel could pick up
tom's stunt double
next daniel stunt double stepped in for
the most dangerous part where the two
had to
actually fling themselves on the floor
no padding
for a crash landing
we never realized how much falling the
harry potter cast really had to do while
filming
stunt double mark maylie stepped in for
daniel in this scene where harry and
voldemort free fall from the tower
but he admits it was really terrifying
to film it was a 55-foot high jump into
cardboard boxes
with no wires attached manly was
uninjured by the fall but rafe finds
stunt double ended up cracking his head
hard on melees when they landed and was
sent to the hospital with a concussion
that was pretty much i think as close to
flying you would get without actually uh
having anything else assisting you the
whomping willow caused its fair share of
destruction
both in the movies and on set for this
scene in prisoner of azkaban
emma watson actually got swung around on
an animatronic branch
her and daniel also had to avoid the
camera as it swung towards them acting
as one of the tree's giant branches
it was all perfectly choreographed so no
one was hurt but emma and daniel did
leave set feeling
a bit dizzy
pretty much all of the quidditch scenes
were a little dangerous
with the cast high up on broomsticks
rigged to move and spin around
but there were a few moments that were
more dangerous than others for one
rupert grint actually got hit in the
face with a quaffle while filming his
scene as a keeper
but what's even more dangerous is how
they'd do crash landings
by having stunt performers swing high
into the air and then take off towards a
landing mat
which is something i use in the circus
daniel said filming on a broom was
already pretty scary because it was so
high up and a very painful place to sit
but imagine if he had to fall from a
broom like his stunt double did
mark maylie's least favorite and most
dangerous scene to film
was this one where harry falls off his
broom after coming face to face with a
dementor
mark was wrapped in wire and winched 55
feet up in the air
then he had to swing upside down with
his head towards the ground
and spin as he fell to the mat below
it's one stunt he's happy
never to repeat again
the harry potter films often use animal
actors on set which means they had to be
careful to avoid any animal related
injuries when malfoy gets turned into a
ferret they used a real ferret
he was pretty well behaved but jaime
waylett who plays crab
had to take some precautions to keep
himself from getting scratched up and
injured
he wore two pairs of pants for this
scene one they put the ferret inside and
a thick pair underneath to protect his
legs
it was a good fight it was training
everyone remembers that moment in the
very first film when the kids walk into
the great hall for the first time
but no one would have guessed that this
scene was actually dangerous
if you look up you can see tons of
floating candles and apparently
they were all really lit and held up by
wires but that ended up causing
a huge problem the candles kept burning
through the wires and then they would
fall onto the actor's heads
they were only able to get one take of
the real candles before they decided
things were getting
too dangerous and the rest was done with
cgi
we'll leave you with a fun look at one
of the stunt performers harry potter
super fan
nicholas danes always a fan of the books
he auditioned to double as a quidditch
player and eventually got to live out
his dream doing dangerous stunts like
this one
thanks for watching and check out our
channel for more magical content